Phylis Schlafly who campaigned very very
proactively against communism against
abortion against the equal rights
amendment has passed away at the age of
92 she founded the Eagle Forum a very
conservative organization back in 1975 a
few people emailed me saying David how
come on Monday you didn't cover her
passing while on Monday we were off for
Labor Day how come he didn't cover it on
Tuesday that was a fair question but it
was because we had segment producer and
intern Noah Ferguson working on a little
compilation of the some of the
highlights of Phyllis Schlafly
interviews with me because I've
interviewed her something like four or
five times let's take a look at some of
those moments now where did you get the
idea that Latinos don't understand the
Bill of Rights they don't understand
that the purpose of our Constitution is
to restrict government we just simply
have a unique system and they they
better realize it and that's why we have
a great country and that's why most of
the rest of the world wanted to come
here they simply have different systems
of government and and lifestyle and I
think that you certainly I certainly do
believe that America is unique and
better than any other country I think
the American people absolutely demand
that we lock up the border make it
secure before we discuss anything else
in the what do we do about those who are
undocumented and in the country now in a
perfect world if you were to decide what
do we do about those people those
millions of people okay so they can be
here but they can't work they can't get
a legal job miss schlafly a pleasure is
always to have you I read your recent
article about funding pre-k you are
against funding pre-k tell us a little
bit about why yes well as the famous dad
used to say where's the beef if you
actually look at the net financial
effect of pre-k there are significant
cost savings to the federal state and
low
governments that are involved to having
universal pre-k special education
services for example which are very
expensive the need for those is reduced
drastically when you have access to
universal pre-k well I would have to
examine for every dollar that is
invested in pre-k the total lifetime
stimulus so to speak of that dollar
invested in pre-k is somewhere between
three dollars and seventy eight cents
and as much as ten dollars depending on
the study you look at this is a very
fiscally conservative investment in the
future of the country well I I i think
those so-called facts have to be
carefully evaluated that's what the
studies do they evaluate these these
statements well do you equate americans
to christians no but i think there are
two thoughts of obama i think he does
not want to think that america is
superior in any way and that translates
into our whole effort to maintain
military superiority which i believe we
should have not not just be strong but
be superior because that way our friends
will rely on us and our enemies will
respect us okay so now we're really
getting into the meat of this you do you
believe that christians are better than
everybody else well yes i do you do the
majority of domestic American terrorism
has had nothing to do with with Muslims
that's just data from the FBI I don't
know if you would dispute that data well
there certainly can Christians believe
in original sin and there are a lot of
people who do commit crimes and no
question about that and we have laws
against these crimes and in most cases
they are punished and I honestly I don't
think that's relevant
see I I'm finding a double standard in
terms of what you include is relevant
and what you exclude and I'll kind of
just sum it up and then of course as I
always do I'll give you a chance to
comment well I do think it's fine for
Americans to be patriotic and think our
country is best so I'm getting the sense
that you've just made up your mind
regardless of the facts yes I call that
patriotism oh so patriotism is having a
position that is not influenced by facts
you're saying no that's not true I think
it's very influenced by fact that
America is the best the fairest the most
successful of society in our country
today and I'm proud of it and I think
Obama should respect it and not try to
compare us all right and you won't be
influenced by FBI data or anything else
that's your position and that's what you
strongly feel I certainly won't be
influenced by FBI data to think that the
Americans are just as bad as the Muslims
that's correct there was always
something sort of endearing about my
interactions with Phyllis Schlafly
I remember moments where I would
basically say to her it sounds like
actually the the sort of truth is the
opposite of what you're saying the facts
at least seemed to show that and she
would sometimes say yeah you know that
may actually be now it didn't change her
opinion in any way she was sticking with
her opinion no matter what the facts
were but she actually sometimes
recognized that I was making a pretty
good case against whatever argument it
was that she was making and here's my
sort of final thought on the legacy of
Phyllis Schlafly in spite of her
policies being very anti feminist she
was the leader of a political
organization that she created and ran
since 1975 the mere existence of the
Eagle Forum and Phyllis Schlafly x' role
there is in a way directly counter to
her anti-feminist beliefs and Rachel you
mentioned this earlier in the show with
regard to gretchen carlson where now she
became the victim of just the rampant
boys club sexual harassment at Fox News
and she received a twenty million dollar
settlement for it etc although at least
as far as the
characters she played on the air was the
exact opposite of that and I kind of
feel like Phyllis Schlafly because she
created this organization in 1975 at a
time when most of this type of activism
really was being done by men her legacy
may actually be the opposite with regard
to feminism of what she even lobbied for
yeah it's interesting how she can kind
of have this almost counterintuitive
dichotomy of kind of what she was kind
of putting forth in terms of her morals
and her values and what she was trying
to get accomplished which was kind of in
almost opposition to how she was
actually acting by getting them
accomplished no doubt about it and I
will remember her fondly not for her
politics but because she actually was a
nice person to speak to on the show